there you you you've been told in this
generation us two that there's one Quran
absolutely the same way every word
letter for letter dot for DOT you know
is the exact same no matter where you go
in the world that's been that's been the
myth and that myth thanks to the
internet has been broken has been
shattered because now anyone can go on
the internet and access the HS Quran
Quran the durri Quran Quran C Quran KH
Quran this is the first I hear of any of
these honestly whether it was all the
way from Adam to Muhammad I like what
you just said the same message surrender
to the one God I like what you just said
you said that you are basing your belief
on the consistency of the prophets Al
together I like that answer do you all
right so let me give you something Torah
Moses taugh Moses taught this he says in
Deuteronomy chter 14 verse1 he says to
the children of Israel he says you are
the sons of the most high God that's
what that's what God revealed through
Moses that the children of Israel are
children of God Prophet Malachi chapter
3 he says God is our father who created
us God is our Our Father who created us
Malachi so we got Moses we got Malachi
here's Isaiah Isaiah says God is our
father who made us the Potter who mowed
us that's Isaiah chapter 63 so we got
Moses we got Malachi we got Isaiah we
got David in the Psalms who says about
the Messiah that God says Messiah today
you will be my son and I will be to you
a father so David says that God is the
father of the Messiah so you got Moses
saying that God is a father Malachi says
God is a father Isaiah says God is a
father David says God is a father and
then Jesus comes and says for God sent
his own his son into the world to save
the world John 3:16 so all the prophets
agree that God is the father so why
don't you in your belief all the
prophets agree he's the father in my
belief I reject that any of the prophets
said he is the father whether it's David
Isaiah Jesus regardless of what prophet
it was they surrendered to one true God
we are his slaves his creation we are
how do you know what how do you know
what they said let me explain something
to you in my belief there are miracles
to prove
prophecy the prophets came there are
Miracles that came when Moses came what
was his Miracle so he could so people
could believe that he is sent by God the
10 plagues on Egypt yes and when he um
opened up the sea the the what is it the
Red Sea or whatever and they all crossed
and all that and when they tried to do
all the spells on him and it all failed
and they couldn't you know when he when
PHA wait wait how do you know it was the
Red Sea isn't it I mean it is but how
did you know that it's I think it's
written in the Quran that it's the Red
Sea I'm not sure it's not it's not
written in the Quran is red well Egypt
the Red Sea geographically come on let's
not focus right here let's move on to
there's a reason why I'm bringing this
up it's really important to our
conversation the reason why you know
that detail that because there were
there was more ocean bodies of ocean
around but the Red Sea specifically is
mentioned in the Torah that I have in
the
Bible so you're getting this information
these details about what happened from
the Bible while at the same it's written
in the Quran too no it's not it it's
written the whole story of Moses is
written in the Quran they might not have
said that he parted the Red Sea but they
said that he did part the sea now I
personally I personally when I said the
Red Sea I thought of it geographically
because I know the Red Sea is by Egypt
so that's why I said that well so this
is my thing though you can have because
you know if you're talking about
splitting the body of water you got the
N River over there yeah few bodies of
water big bodies of water by true and
you got you got the Red Sea how you know
which one which one was split because he
didn't say because they didn't say that
he split the River or the Nile or
whatever they said he split the sea the
Quran doesn't say which body of water is
split okay I'm not gonna argue that
because I'm not sure of my answer what
what's the right thing to be but that's
not my point my point is every Prophet
had a miracle that was Moses Jesus was
born from a virgin he had the ability to
heal people he had the ability he had
many different Miracles that proved that
he is God's that he is um God's son
God's messenger sorry it sound like you
about to say God's son I was about to I
was about to make that he's God's
messenger you're making me you almost
you almost had a fraud and slip yeah it
almost slipped I'm not gonna lie and
then and then you have Muhammad
Muhammad's Miracle what was it did you
notice that no nothing nothing that that
Moses got or Jesus got but you know what
Muhammad's miracle was you didn't have
one yes he did no he didn't Quran says
he didn't do any Miracles the Quran is
his Miracle ah come on it
is the beauty of the Quran is that you
cannot change one word that you cannot
replace one word without it being known
it cannot be tampered
with there are different words in in the
Quran in other qurans that now would
show that the quran's not a miracle
Quran is one and there is no other
there's no version there's no different
words there's no different that and if
anybody body tries to make their own
version of it it is picked out right
away and it's known that it's false it's
not true so that's you cannot mess with
now wait pause because you said
something extremely important okay so
I'm asking you if the Quran different
versions with different words would that
prove that the Quran is not a miracle
there are no different versions that's
what I'm trying to I understand I'm just
asking it yes of course if there are and
if they can put if somebody can bring me
a book that is not the Quran and say
this is the true version of the Quran
I'm not going to be able to tell that
that's the Quran and it's a different
it's the same teachings it's the same
whatever it's not the same exact book
then yeah but they cannot do it the way
the words are put together the way that
no because this is not a me the words
that are in the Quran are not man-made
they are a message from God directly
through gab Gabriel to Muhammad these
are not words I know you believe that
but himself try to change it he can I'm
addressing sister I'm addressing what
you said directly I can show you myself
right now multiple different Quran
versions and I bet you any scholar will
be able to pinpoint which ones are the
wrong ones and which one is the real one
actually it's funny that you say that
because the scholars used to debate over
this in early Islam used to debate over
which readings were correct they debated
over the translations how their how they
understood it how they all Arabic sister
all Arabic different words no I
understand it's all Arabic but for
example I'll give you a poem I'll me and
you could read the same poem I'll
translate it or I'll understand it and
perceive it in a certain way and you
might perceive it in a completely
different way I know what you mean
you're talking about interpretation
talking exactly those are the
differences but it's not the actual no
sister it's not been interpretation it's
not translation it's literally different
Arabic words that they are fighting over
to say which one was actually the
correct reading not correct
understanding the correct reading what
did it actually say have you have you
heard like for example have you heard of
the recitation of Huffs no right what
about
war okay so just to like break this down
just simply uh HS recitation of the
Quran HS is a person who got his
recitation of the Quran from a man named
Assam okay who got his from I forgot who
gave it to him but eventually they tried
to go back to uan so and there's
problems with that chain too but just to
keep it simple so HS learned his
recitation his reading of the Quran from
Assam that version of the Quran is the
most popular version of the Quran today
that's the one that was actually what's
the word when they make it official they
made they made his Quran official in
1924 in Egypt okay they're used to be
different qurans in the schools and
stuff like that but they used to they
didn't want to confuse the educational
system so they there you go thank you
guys standardized they standardized the
HS reading of the Quran over the others
okay however in
Morocco they standardized the warsh
reading of the Quran warsh is another
person who got his recitation from
someone okay okay you're confusing
something these are people these are
Scholars that are translating or
explaining it in their ways these are
not people that wrote it there's there's
the all those people that they have
nothing to do with the readings of the
Quran system nothing so you have Hop's
reading of the Quran that was
standardized above the other qurans that
happens because there's multiple qurans
out
there okay can argue that tomorrow
morning you can't change my mind you you
seem like a you seem like a person who
thinks and like you like I've been
enjoying the conversation with you if I
were to show you certain differences
between a h Quran and let's say like a
war Quran for example you would see that
for yourself right and then like it's
not my words you can't you're not taking
my words for you know because I know
that you have your own beliefs and
convictions so my words don't mean they
if I show it to you though will you
didn't accept you know what what you see
before your eyes I don't have the the
proper knowledge to be able to tell you
which one is actually the Quran I'm not
that knowledgeable to be able to tell
you which one is fake which one is real
but at the end of the day it is one
Quran there's no different versions of
it but what I wanted to the message that
I was trying to deliver to you let me
bring my point across to me my personal
belief is that whether it's the Tor the
Torah
Bible or the Quran it's like a three
part book part one part two part three
and at the end of the day the message is
one we are all supposed to follow one
true God submit to one true God from
Adam all the way to Muhammad and every
prophet in between had the same message
I do not believe that we should be
against each other I believe that we
should respect each other and and
respect each other's beliefs and
continue with the teachings if you read
part one that's the Torah part two
that's the Bible part three it's the
Quran but at the end of the day the
Quran is the final sealed book it is the
word that nobody can temper with I know
you believe that but here's my thing
again when you say that you don't have
the knowledge to tell me which Quran is
the right one no somebody triy to
replace a sentence or replace a word
don't have the scholar the the knowledge
to be able to tell you which one is fake
and I'm going to tell you I'm going to
tell you this right now too your
Scholars don't either your Scholars your
early Islamic scholars tabari C people
like that they used to they used to they
were count where people used to fight
over different readings of the Quran
over different versions of the Quran
they used to fight over this stuff
because this stuff is real and it exists
it's a and I know it's not your fault I
believe that you're probably just paired
something you you learned and grown up
with there you you you've been told in
this generation us two that there's one
Quran absolutely the same way every word
letter for letter dot for DOT you know
is the exact same no matter where you go
in the world that's been that's been the
myth and that myth thanks to the
internet has been broken has been
shattered
because now anyone can go on the
internet and access the hffs Quran War
Quran the durri Quran Kon Quran K Quran
K
Quran I hear of any of these honestly
say that again this is the first I hear
of any of these honestly and that and
that's okay you know like we we grow and
we learn like you know we we got to do
we got to do research and and then look
into these things so like that's why I'm
not you know beating you over the head
with this stuff
I want toage because you so respectful
and you have a conviction and a passion
that I do respect and so I I believe and
I'm hoping and I'm trusting that if I'm
giving you this information that you
will go and check it out just check it
out I check it out definitely okay and
then come I want you to come back too
like I want I want to us to talk more I
want to see I want you to tell me what
you found or things you I like to not to
your audience though please don't take
my words as as I'm speaking for all
Muslims because I only know what I know
I'm speaking for myself so it's all good
no judgment here it's all good yeah it's
all good so please uh follow me come
back and let's let's talk again and see
what you see what you got okay all right
nice talking to you you too take care